so a lot of you guys have been asking
for Ultimate Spider-Man and I figured
we'd give it a shot and it's really kind
of cool here because ultimate
Spider-Man's really where the Ultimate
Universe began and it really makes sense
too because those of you guys who are
new to Marvel Comics right now all new
all different Marvel is designed to be a
combination of the Ultimate Universe and
the traditional Marvel Earth 616
Universe molded into one which is just
now called Earth Prime I still call it
earth616 because everything is the same
with the exception of the fact that the
Ultimate Universe continuity was kind of
rolled or at least the characters were
rolled in and some of their history
Remains the Same it was really more just
like Concepts that were thrown in there
but at the very least it keeps things uh
relatively familiar for people who are
coming from both sides but Ultimate
Spider-Man is really where the Ultimate
Universe originated from now this really
started with Brian Michael Bendis and
Mark Bagley I think and the idea was to
quite literally just take the entire
concept of Marvel Comics and to make it
more updated now this really came out of
the near collapse of the color book
industry and I'm not really going to go
into that too deep just because we've
had a lot of discussions on that but it
was really just rooted in the idea that
people were buying com mix under the
belief that they would be worth a lot of
money later on down the line the issue
is that the more of something people buy
the less value that it has and so
because of that it's believed that
Comics will be worth a ton of money
resulted in Publishers just releasing
more and more comics which they
essentially just flooded the market so I
met the comics themselves got to the
point where they were worth almost
nothing people stopped buying them and
then it led to the near collapse of the
industry but the idea here was that with
model recovering or Marvel trying to
recover from this near collapse on one
side you had jokasada running the Marvel
publishing line with regards to all
their different concepts and all their
different teams and so on and so forth
but it was also the idea of trying to
update the continuity for the modern
reader so that kids who were getting
into comic books in the year 2000 you
know who are wanting to get into comic
books of 2001 2002 so on and so forth
could jump in and see their characters
updated in contemporary ways and so it
made sense to really just start with
Spider-Man because Peter Parker is the
face of Marvel Comics when people think
of Marvel they don't really think of the
Incredible Hulk first they don't really
think of Captain America first they
think of Spider-Man and so because of
that it made sense to grab Peter Parker
enroll them in now for those of you guys
who have seen the Sam Raimi Spider-Man
movies or who have seen the uh I guess
Sony's attempt to I guess Sony's
disastrous attempt really to try to
reboot the franchise with Amazing
Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield a lot of
what we're going to see in the early
part of this story in terms of his
Origins is almost image for image what
we saw in the movie so the reason why is
because almost all the cinematic movies
that are made based on comic book
characters are largely rooted in the
Ultimate Universe they're very rarely
ever rooted in the main Marvel Universe
one of the reasons why you don't see a
lot of similarities there you'll see
more similarities you know for example
between the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and the Ultimate Universe than you will
and the main Marvel Universe the only
exception to that is like Captain
America's origin story you know he was
the original Super Soldier instead of
Nick Fury so on and so forth but the
fact remains here that what this does is
it initially picks up at Oscorp and
again this is just one of the updated
things instead of just simply saying
there was an irradiated spider once upon
a time that bit Peter Parker we're kind
of given some motive behind it and what
we learned is that really Norman Osborne
is working on a substance columns now a
lot of this ties into the work of Peter
Parker's parents and that'll be an
ongoing theme that'll take place later
on in the publication history but again
all of this really comes out of the
super soldier serum for those of you
guys who saw my video or who didn't see
my video rather on Ultimate Origins we
had talked about how the first
successful super soldier in the Ultimate
Universe was Nick Fury after him came
Captain America came Wolverine with
Wolverine came the origin of mutants so
on and so forth Bruce Banner
experimented on himself became the
Incredible Hulk but with the exception
of Steve Rogers there was nobody else
who was the Super Soldier there was no
one else had really been able to
duplicate the formula in the same
capacity and because of this the work of
Peter Parker's parents was rooted in the
idea of trying to crack the super
soldier serum and trying to find a way
to make it perfect so that it could be
used the issue with this is that Norman
Osborne's kind of trying to continue
this trend but also use it for his own
purposes and of course what he says is
that they've basically been using this
for using animal testing one of which is
a spider now from here we kind of jumped
to Peter Parker's personal life and this
really isn't done for anything spec
tacular this is really just to kind of
give us an idea of where Peter Parker is
coming from that he's a kid who's picked
on he's a kid who's made fun of it's
really just Brian Michael benison and
Bagley refreshing us with his character
like hey guys this is the Peter Parker
that you know he's basically the nerd
he's the outcast you know not really of
pariah but he's certainly the kid who's
like the geek you know the
quintessential geek he doesn't quite get
the respect of the girl Mary Jane Watson
is a friend but as far as we could tell
their friends they're never going to be
anything besides that they're friends
and it's really because she just kind of
stuck him in the friend zone that really
seems to be the direction that things
are going in but we also get a little
bit of humor here in the sense that
they're at a mall right now and so we
basically have Peter Parker you know his
uncle Uncle Ben show up and kind of try
to bring the two together hey Peter why
don't you say something to Mary Jane
Watson instead of like you know being
awkward like why don't you just say hey
let's go out sometime or something along
those lines but of course Peter can't
quite pull it together now of course
back at school it's much the same way I
mean of course we learned that Harry
Osborne is kind of like the rich Cool
Kid Flash Thompson is the school jock
you know he's the star of the basketball
team Peter Parker just doesn't quite fit
in when it comes to sports again and
it's just kind of this roundabout
explanation of hey here's Peter Parker's
life here's the before shot now you're
about to get the after shot now with
regards to this after segment again
Peter Parker and Harry Osborne are
really more friends by circumstance I
wouldn't really consider them to be like
the best of friends it's really one of
these issues where Peter Parker
basically does his homework for him and
Harry Osborne is like Peter's connection
to what it would be like to be cool what
we also get here is a little bit of
backstory we get a little bit of
exposition we don't get a whole lot we
learn that Peter Parker's parents had
died but we also learned that Peter's
father had been working on this adhesive
substance of course where we know just
by virtue of foreshadowing that'll go on
to become the substance that Peter uses
for his webbing but at the moment he's
never really been able to crack it he
hasn't been able to figure it out the
other half of this is that for Harry
Osborne himself his relationship with
his father is very very strained and
this is something that I really really
liked about what it is that Bendis wrote
Because this is why I say when it comes
to businesses writing bindis is grade A
when it's developing characters when it
comes to story arcs when it comes to
like major crossover events he's kind of
spotty but if you hand Bend us a
character and say flash this character
out or if you go to business to say make
a character and flesh them out business
will do one hell of a job doing it
because he's just great when it comes to
working on individual characters the
struggle between Harry Osborne and
Norman Osborne is really more of a
situation of Harry wanting the respect
of his father but also just wanting some
measure of attention from his father the
issue here is that Osborne spares no
time for his son it's really just one of
these things where he's just too busy he
doesn't really worry about him too much
you know there's always somebody else to
make sure that Harry has what he needs
and so because of this they're not
nearly as close as you would expect
there's not a real animosity or hatred
it's really more just two ships that
just kind of Sail by each other and they
never really have time to talk or say
anything and so because of this we jump
to Osborne Industries you know basically
we jump to the incident when Peter's
bitten by a radioactive spider and again
Bendis takes things fast I mean banders
does not slow down here I mean it starts
zero to 60. it immediately takes off the
spider that had been experimented on was
supposed to have been kept in
containment the issue is that the spider
was able to make its way out and of
course it bites Peter Parker this is why
I say it happens super fast now the
reason why Dennis is doing this too is
because business is also paying homage
to Amazing Fantasy number 15 the way it
was originally done what I mean here is
back in the early 1960s when Marvel was
coming onto the scene I mean DC was like
the publisher I mean it was DC Comics
you had a few here and there but if you
were reading comics you were reading DC
and that's really all there was to it I
mean science fiction was so popular but
in terms of superheroes it was DC I mean
they were the sole star of the game for
the most part and because of this Marvel
literally just had to create Origins
over the course of like a page or two
and send them out and let the story kind
of unfold on its own and that's what
happened you know when when Stan Lee and
Steve ditko sat down and they said Peter
Parker Spider-Man in Amazing Fantasy
number 15. it was hey he's Peter Parker
he's picked on he's kind of the nerd
they're on a field trip rather he's
bitten by a radioactive spider he
becomes Spider-Man and We're Off to the
Races that's basically how it went like
it was super fast pace Bendis does that
to the same degree here in the sense
that bitten by a radioactive spider
within the first issue and suddenly it
comes on him the difference here is that
we get a little more expansion in terms
of how this works now the main Marvel
Universe Peter Parker got the same
treatment later you're on Down the Line
it was done especially in future Amazing
Spider-Man stories and even stories that
went back and touched on his origin
again but with the whole Ultimate
Universe thing it was a chance for
business and Mark Bagley to sit down and
say okay if we're going to retell the
origin of Peter Parker we've got one
shot at this and so we need to make sure
that we go For Broke we need to give
people the best updated modern origin
story that we could get for Peter Parker
to give him something right off the bat
because remember the purpose of the
Ultimate Universe was not to be as
expansive as the main Marvel Universe
the purpose of the Ultimate Universe was
to be easily accessible tight-knit very
easy to follow and so because of that
the origin stories of characters and
people who were introduced had to follow
much the same way now when it came to
Peter Parker being bitten Osborne and
his guys found out about it pretty fast
the issue with this was that in their
mind there were only really two options
here the first was to basically cover
his medical bills which would be an
admission of guilt or the second is to
simply just wait and let his family sue
them because again they're operating
from a corporate standpoint but what
Norman Osborne says is they're going to
cover the medical bills assuming that he
goes to the hospital they're going to do
it anonymously and then they're gonna
sit back and watch now the reason for
this is because Osborne had been
intending to move towards the direction
of human trials but the issue is that
there was going to be a lot of red tape
he'd have to go through a lot of federal
laws and regulations FDA so on and so
forth in order to allow this to be
tested on people to even begin the
process of doing that but instead to his
luck some kids stumbled into Osborne
Industries was bitten by a spider and no
one really knows what the effects may be
and so by just kind of sitting back and
watching letting these things unfold
Osborne's hoping to smooth things over a
bit with regards to Uncle Ben and Aunt
May by more or less throwing money at it
and then hoping for the best and so
because of that Peter's life begins to
take this really interesting turn and
that's what I like about this because
it's just super cool it's super quick
things move relatively fast so the sense
that as he's being picked on by one of
the kids named Kong I want to say that
his name is Kenneth McFarland I think
his fighter says kicks in and he
immediately counters now again Peter's
learning all of this stuff for the very
first time this is all brand new to him
but every time or at least it seems at
the beginning when he has this
experience he begins to pass out of
course he wakes up in the hospital
little oh no no everything's fine it's
okay not a great big huge deal you know
they take a little bit of blood work and
that's about it now when the blood
work's taken to be tested by the nurses
a guide by the name of Mr Shaw actually
takes it and ends up bringing it back to
Norman Osborne now when they get it back
to Osborne the testing that they do
basically reveals uh it seems to be
killing him and this is where things get
a little bit murky following this
Revelation that Peter Parker is
essentially going to die by virtue of
the spider that bit him he's fed banana
bread by Aunt May now we don't know
exactly what it is that's going on here
what I was reading through this I was
kind of like well maybe I'm reading a
little bit more between the lines that I
should it may be that just potassium was
the missing ingredient but by literally
serving him an entire loaf of banana
bread Peter's Powers continue to
progress on normally and so the idea
seems to be here the potassium was the
missing link it was the one thing he
needed to keep his powers from killing
and the reason why is we'll find out
later on that he's actually getting
better it's working in his benefit but
the idea here is that Mr Shaw had
essentially been contracted by Norman
Osborne to basically kill Peter Parker
because remember they're operating under
the assumption that he's going to die
anyway and so if he's gonna die anyway
and he's just hit by a rogue card that
things will be fine now something that I
want to point out here is that Mr Shaw
is not Sebastian Shaw of the hellfire
club at least not that I know of this is
just a random guy named Mr Shaw I'm not
that familiar with the Ultimate Universe
I don't even know if the hellfire club
exists in the Ultimate Universe it might
or it might have been mentioned in some
form or fashion I'm pretty sure
Sebastian Shaw exists but if I'm wrong
about that I'm sure you guys will
correct me down in the comments section
but the fact remains here that when the
vehicle as it's driven by Mr Shaw you
know goes to hit Peter Parker of course
his reactions kick in he's able to jump
over it and uh when Shaw reports back to
Norman Osborne he's like you know don't
do anything we need to keep an eye on
him now from here the Peter begins using
his own Ingenuity and begins kind of
poking around doing some experimentation
testing his own blood and comes to the
realization that he basically has spider
powers he has the agility the strength
the reflexes of a spider now it blows
his mind that that's a possibility but
the other half of this is that his
studies his whole experience here is
changing the very fundamental course of
his life now the reason why this works
out is because Brian Michael bandis
removes the element of like puberty as
we would call it and replaces it with
being bitten by a radioactive spider and
what I mean here is that as teenagers
you know when we grow when we become you
know 13 14 15 16 years old we become
rebellious it's just how we are we test
our limits we want freedom we want to be
able to get out there we want to do our
own thing we want to be adults we're
rushing to grow up not realizing that by
the time you know we become adults we
want to go back to being teenagers again
it's just one of those crazy Circles of
life that we all experience but with
regards to his relationship with Aunt
May and Uncle Ben it becomes very
strenuous here and the reason why is
because Peter Parker's always been a kid
that kept his head in the books you know
valued his education over everything
else but with him studying these Powers
he's basically blowing off school this
is being reported to Aunt May and Uncle
Ben and they're like what's going on
with you why are you doing this and
Peter Parker is taking very much the
rebellious teenage round of well you
know don't worry about me I've got it
together leave me alone and so again the
last little bit of his power at least in
this first issue anyway um the last
little bit of his power that begins to
manifest is of course his ability to
crawl on walls now at this point
business begins to focus a little bit
more on Peter Parker in relation to how
he uses his powers because it plays out
exactly the way that we would expect if
we were a teenage kid who was 15 16
years old and we suddenly had enhanced
strength speed agility and so on we
would use it to become cool we'd use the
face off against the various bullies
that gave us a hard time and that's
exactly what happens flash tops and
starts making unwanted passes at Mary
Jane Watson of course Peter Parker steps
up and says hey man get out of here in
response Flash Thompson basically picks
a fight Peter Dodges him at every turn
goes to block one of his punches and
it's like hitting a brick wall flash
Thompson's hand breaks in the process
now this is where business begins to
segue away from the idea of Peter
Parker's Powers being contained only to
him to them having impacts on everybody
else around him the first is that with
Kong you know hanging out with Harry
Osborne telling him about everything
that was going on with Flash Thompson
Norman Osborne hears all this and says
hey man like I'd love it if you were to
bring Peter Parker and yourself over to
Osborne Industries I can show you guys
everything you know show you all that
cool stuff you guys will have a great
time you know and here he's like yeah
sure anything to spend time with my dad
you know somebody's like yeah he's
definitely on board with that the other
half of this is the parents of Flash
Thompson threatened to suit Aunt May and
Uncle Ben so because of this it's also
the idea there's ramifications now for
them they're effectively broke and so
the idea of how it is that they're going
to pay a 2500 medical bill really kind
of baffles them and so what this does is
it allows Peter the process of basically
going through and experimenting with his
powers a little bit more realizing how
strong he is and being able to throw
around cars but it also allows the story
to segue Into the Now famous of course
gym scene now uh with regards to Osborne
Industries I kind of touch on this for a
second when Peter and Harry get over
here it really is basically just an
ambush but we're also shown a lot of
characters who are going to go on to
play major roles later on of course Dr
Octopus dock is an employee at Osborne
Industries and so on but Peter Parker is
essentially just hit with a needle where
blood's taken and then he basically just
bails out you know because for him it's
a terrifying situation to suddenly have
blood drawn not only that Doc Ock begins
talking with Norman Osborne and says hey
look what we thought was happening
before is not happening Peter Parker's
not dying Peter Parker's getting better
not only that he's developing abilities
the things that he can do basically put
him on par with a spider he's
effectively a spider in human form he
has all the same abilities proportional
to a spider and so Osborne says you know
the only thing that we can do now since
we have a human out there that can be
tested is we have to continue the
process we need to repeat the test we
need to see if it can be done again and
so he says I'm gonna try it on myself
and of course we know this will lead
into the Green Goblin now the way the
Green Goblins depicted here is actually
really really cool but to hold off on
that for a second picking up with a
wrestling match this is actually not the
most important thing ever this does not
play out the same way that it did with
regards to the Spider-Man movie you know
understand Remy where the guy robbed the
wrestling owner ringer ring guy whatever
was and then took off with the money
instead that actually happens through a
different situation but the fact remains
here that it does allow Peter to explore
his powers a little bit more make a
little bit money for himself so on and
so forth but it also basically gives him
his name in the sense that because of
course all this is fixed uh he'd never
really been given a name before so the
idea was that in the middle of all this
commotion and carrying on and so on and
so forth the name is basically given to
him is Spider-Man because when he's
asked what's your name he's like well I
don't really know I mean I guess you
know the spider is what he initially
goes with and the ring commentator says
The Amazing Spider-Man and so from that
point going forward everybody's like
Spider-Man now he's a huge ring
attraction but it's where the name comes
from it's where the name sticks the
other half of this is what he's paid by
the ring announcer he basically says hey
man you look like a goof like you look
ridiculous so I've had this costume
worked up for you throw it on and it's
the traditional Spider-Man costume minus
the spider Insignia and the webbing and
so of course Peter says hey look I need
to go ahead and throw the saw now from
here we get into the introduction of the
Green Goblin or the very least the
transformation of the Green Goblin
that's why I say things happen really
really really fast in this story Bendis
waits for no man um he really just kind
of throws things out quick in the sense
that now Harry Osborne basically
Witnesses the entire event take place
although he's not really supposed to but
it's really just Norman Osborne being
tested Doctor Octopus of course
relishing experience and then whatever
happens next results in a multitude of
people being killed you know a multitude
of people all being attacked Doctor
Octopus is of course alive but most
everybody else is dead here the issue
issue with this is that you know with
Harry Osborne being alive he's the one
person who is actually going to come
forward at least reveal to Peter Park
and most of his friends anyway what it
is that took place here but we know this
is basically a circumstance where Norman
Osborne was transformed into the Green
Goblin and immediately started tearing
things apart now one of the big
differences this is something that I
actually want to point out here one of
the big differences between what Brian
Michael Bendis is doing here with the
relation between Peter Parker and the
Green Goblin is how fast they learn
about each other now the reason why I
say this is well I guess we'll get to
that here in a second but for right now
I want to transition to basically the
death of Uncle Ben with Uncle Ben being
killed this comes by way of a guy who
essentially just robbed the deli Peter
Parker doesn't do anything to stop the
guy now it's not because of the fact
that the Delhi owner did anything to him
it's not because of the fact that the
deli owners somehow you know wouldn't
give him a deal on a sandwich or
anything like that there was no real
Grudge there it was simply that Peter
Parker just didn't feel like doing
anything he didn't want to have anything
to do with that now something that I had
basically backpedaled on here something
that I hadn't really gone too deep into
with this particular thing is the idea
of the phrase vocabin with great power
comes great responsibility and the
reason why I say that is because there
is a major fight that takes place
between okoban and Peter Parker when
Peter Parker gets home after letting
this robber Escape he's confronted with
the fact that his grades are basically
slumping and of course again Peter
Parker begins to lash out and says you
guys don't understand what's going on
with me you guys can't begin to
understand what's going on this is
ridiculous I'm cool now I have abilities
you know I'm capable he doesn't really
go into specifics but it's basically
just the angsty teenager lashing out at
his parental figures and so because of
this he takes off and he actually ends
up going to hang out with Kong for a
while then you know great big huge
party's throw now at this party there's
a girl named Liz and Liz seems to be the
girl that most people enjoy the company
of and in the middle of all this you
know Mary Jane Watson walks in of course
Mary Jane Watson sees Peter Parker and
Liz it's really more of just kind of
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time it's not really what it seems but
in her storming out and taking off when
Peter Parker goes to chase after her
he's confronted by Uncle Ben now this is
when Uncle Ben says hey look I
understand you have things going on I
understand that there's stuff going on
in here life that you can't tell us
about now keep in mind Uncle Ben's not a
fool but Uncle Ben has no earthly clue
that Peter Parker's Spider-Man I mean he
doesn't know that all he knows is that
Peter Parker is just going through what
he believes to be normal teenage angsty
you know angry at the world trying to
figure himself out kind of stuff but
what he says is your father had a figure
of speech that served him well and it is
this if you have the power to change
something then you should use the power
to change something if you have the
power to make the world a better place
it's your responsibility to make the
world a better place with great power
comes great responsibility Peter Parker
of course responds to this by saying if
he knew so much then why is he dead so
again this is really Peter just failing
to hear the words of Uncle Ben and it's
just kind of this updated retelling of
the last argument that the two of them
have and why Peter will carry so much
guilt around now of course with Peter
leaving you know lashing out and then
eventually coming back home again when
he gets there Uncle Ben's been killed
now with regards to the death of Uncle
Ben what we basically learned is that
the man that Peter Parker had allowed to
escape had basically just run up inside
the house of Peter Parker's family while
he was gone demanded money from Aunt May
and Uncle Ben Uncle Ben cracked a joke
saying hey man you probably got more
money than we do and the guy just shot
him for it of course you know he turned
code and ran away in response Peter
Parker goes after him but the entire
time of this happens while Peter
Parker's taunting this guy while Peter
Parker's striking Terror Into the Heart
of this guy he's dealing with a lot of
inner turmoil here despite his anger and
how he would like to believe he actually
is and Peter Parker is good at heart
Peter Parker is a good human being at
the moment he's angry but he also has to
reconcile this with the fact that if he
were to kill this guy it would sit with
him for the rest of his life not only
that the reason why Uncle Ben's dead is
very much the fault of Peter Parker a
lot of really hardcore Spider-Man fans
would contest that they would say well
there's no way for you to know that
okoban would have been killed by this
guy even if Peter Parker had stopped he
would have been killed by somebody else
or something like that it was fate
okabida was always going to die that may
be but what we do know with absolute
certainty is that if Peter Parker had
stepped up and stopped this guy that guy
wouldn't have killed him and so because
of this Peter Parker looks at this and
says that it's basically his fault he's
the reason why his Uncle Ben had been
killed here and so because of that while
the whole situation is more or less a
standoff with Captain Stacy you know
leading the charge and everything Peter
Parker basically defeats this guy throws
him out a window with a rope attached
doesn't really hang him you know just
kind of goes about the window for the
police to deal with and then calls it a
day in response to this is Peter Parker
coming to the realization that there was
truth in his father's words that even if
the world didn't know that Peter Parker
had fantastic abilities he knew he had
fantastic abilities and it was his job
to step up and stop that robber when he
first saw him doing something and so
because of this Peter Parker basically
begins the process of becoming
Spider-Man as we know him in the sense
that he becomes a superhero now what
what Bendis does here is he says hey we
don't need a great big huge grandiose
scale of events we don't need 19 story
arcs showing us Peter Parker becoming
Spider-Man Peter Parker becoming
Spider-Man is a Timeless Tale the death
of Uncle Ben will be a Timeless story
from now until the end of time in 500
years when people are talking about
Spider-Man the death of Uncle Ben will
be a core part of a story it may have
been retold 200 times between now and
then but it'll always be the same Uncle
Ben is killed by a guy that Spider-Man
could have stopped and so because of
that Venice is just like hey here's a
one-page collage of like Spider-Man
being a hero because that's really all
we need and that's the greatest thing
about this that's one of the things that
made this so cool is because here's the
nitty-gritty here's what you guys need
more so than that Mary Jane Watson sits
down with Peter Parker and it's this
moment between the two of them dead had
long since been coming it was really the
closeness of the situation that brought
them together one of the reasons why
this is so significant and I don't know
how many people would have originally
caught this but one of the reasons why
this is so important is because this
Harkens back to the death of Gwen Stacy
in 1971 when Jerry Conway killed off
Gwen Stacy Mary Jane Watson had always
been depicted as this girl who was very
self-absorbed this girl who only really
cared about herself for me she was a
very successful and beautiful model Gwen
Stacy was always the more down to earth
reasonable girl that Peter Parker was
always going to be with when Jerry
Conway killed her off and brought in
Mary Jane Austin basically had Peter
Parker Mary Jane Watson come together
there was the infamous scene when the
two of them were talking and she'd asked
something about which say said he said
why do you care the only person you care
about is yourself and where she was
inclined to leave she closed the word
stayed and that was the two of them
solidifying that Mary Jane Watson and
Peter Parker will get together the
opposite to a degree happens here in the
sense that it's actually the death of
Uncle Ben that triggers more or less
Mary Jane Watson and Peter Parker
growing closer together which was a
beautiful way to play this particular
scene out but from here Peter Parker
again continues to experiment a little
bit more with his powers then just
doesn't waste a whole lot of time with
Peter Parker mourning Uncle Ben's death
you know it's really just kind of
running through things pretty fast it
doesn't mean he doesn't care it just
means that at the moment Peter Parker
recognizes the value of the lesson that
his Uncle Ben was teaching him and the
idea that Uncle Ben wouldn't want to see
if Peter Parker just sit in a dark room
listening to Evanescence all day long
because of the fact that he died instead
he would want him to go out and to be a
hero to go out and to achieve and to do
great things with his life and so that's
what he does of course he actually
perfects the the adhesive formula that
his father put together and developed
his webbing because of it so you know
with that it really sets the stage for
him to go on and Achieve great things
not only that we basically have the
Green Goblin attacking the school now
the cool thing about this is that with
Norman Osborne the way he's depicted as
the Green Goblin is incredibly awesome I
don't know how his depiction as a Green
Goblin in terms of how he looked was
received by a lot of traditional
Spider-Man fans but I thought it looked
awesome because I was afraid that what
we're gonna get is basically a repeat of
the Green Goblin from the original
Spider-Man comics but I think that if
you're gonna kind of reboot you're going
to reinvigorate I think you got to
reinvigorate across the board you can't
really you know reinvigorate halfway of
course I guess you got to keep
Spider-Man you know design the same for
the most part but when it came to the
Green Goblin he was just this giant
hulking beast and it worked out well now
with regards to what I was saying
earlier about how this was really
horrendous looking at the previous
Stories the Green Goblin first appeared
in The Amazing Spider-Man number 14 and
it was something like 25 issues Before
Peter Parker and the Green Goblin
learned each other's identities so it
was a long time before they learned who
the other was now at this moment Peter
Parker does not know who the Green
Goblin is but of course the Green Goblin
knows who Peter Parker is and of course
the words are kind of slurred and
muddled and so on and so forth and the
Green Goblin effectively just wants to
kill him now the fight is left very
open-ended I mean there's not a whole
lot is left for the imagination I mean
we see them fighting and so on but in
terms of the ending and what happens
it's really just the cops being called
in when you know half the school
implodes on itself and then this fight
between Spider-Man and the Green Goblin
you know leads into the city of New York
itself but It ultimately culminates in
this battle where the Green Goblin
basically falls off a bridge reminiscent
of When Stacy falling to her death and
that's really it I mean he just falls
under the water and we don't really find
out what happens next instead all we
ever really had were just a series of
Green Goblin just muttering the word
Parker and that was really it but what
we end up having is Peter Parker
basically learning the identity of the
Green Goblin by way of Harry Oswald
himself when he says it's my father that
I saw him survive he didn't die he
basically went crazy he burned down the
house he killed my mom he lost his mind
you know he's just out there in left
field someone has to stop him somebody
has to be able to bring him to an end
but at the moment right now you know in
the eyes of Peter Parker no one knows
where the Green Goblin is you know no
one knows where he's at and so at this
point it's really just kind of setting
the stage by Bendis and Mark Bagby
saying hey here's Ultimate Spider-Man
right now he was the first film he
fought in the form of Norman Osborne
hear what his powers are here's his
close-knit group of friends here's his
most likely love interest Mary Jane
Watson and we'll see the introduction of
Gwen Stacy and so on and so forth we'll
see those characters kind of grow and
expand as the series goes on but again
for our seven issue introductory story
arc for the first issue really being
double-sized to be honest it worked out
pretty well and it played out pretty
well like Ultimate Spider-Man was
extremely well received by fans and it
really helped to just kind of like
jettison the Ultimate Universe and a
success uh from the word go but if you
guys are new here the comments explain
make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button to become part of the Rob court
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and uh leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about Ultimate Spider-Man because
I'm kind of curious and now I'm catch
you all later
peace